so meine lieben es geht was sie gleich
sehen werden ist ein neuer spielmodus
dieser spielmodus heißt jetzt darum dass
man in teams gegeneinander antritt und
versucht so eine kleine kugel in die
gegnerischen tore zu schießen das hat
sowas von hawke und ein bisschen von
fußball und wenn euch dieser spielmodus
gefällt wenn ihr auf dem channel
bisschen mehr abwechslung wollt dann
lasst auf jeden fall ein like dann
schaltet hier unbedingt in das das
wichtigste in die kommentare
wenn er abwechslung volt in die
kommentare damit ich werde aufhören
und ja falls diese nicht wollt falls ja
auch nur minecraft sehen wollt dann
lasst mich das auch wissen ist auch
legitim einfach in die kommentare
schreiben
und dann sehen uns gleich ein video
wieder ciao denn ganz hinter irgendwann
geklärt wie büro ist rasiert ist kein
linie die machen taktik marketing mix
los gehts und herzlich willkommen zu den
jackpot einfach mal kurze beschreibung
stories beschreibung farbig beschreibung
der dax so krank dass beschreibung und
farbig auch scheiße ich weiß nicht ob
ich hier unterscheiden ob akw gehen
lassen 123 was es für das fällen eine
finde filme ja sowie kaputte ja sowieso
denn alle schon vom schreien ja ich
schreibe den rheinländer mit
ja genau
wir machen den film auf einmal kommt in
der ganz hinten drin
ja die klett wie borowski rasiert was
ich muss mal scheiße popstars wirklich
verschrauben hier weil ich mir den weg
gemacht
jaja kassiert
immer schön auf abseits aktion jetzt
dran
ja wir haben das gemacht ja ja die
machen taktik marketing-mix genau hatte
jetzt raus zu speyer dallas kidd
denn es zählt einfach denn sie hatte
schwarze ich hab was ich bin der boss
schießen doch nicht weg rasiert denn das
was ihr jetzt alle drei jahre 3 gegen
den 1
es ist mir aber egal das ist mir egal
ich bin da
ich schwöre das war knapp
direkt nehmen müssen
diese basiert jedoch wächst du musst
immer wenn einer von hinten kommt muss
der von vorne com platz machen damit der
von hintenraus schießen kann
jetzt kommt keine von hinter nicht egal
ja wer und kopf an kopf
hierzu drei jahre ist es auch führung
für uns kennt oft direkt was machst du
wie ein schuljunge ausgleich
ja dann ist genau jetzt dennis früher
abspielen ja ja da hast du das abseits
drin habe egal findet kommt die könntest
nicht wetten die kennen das nicht
wirklich weg mit dir los mach djs angst
dass jetzt ja ruhig auf der schnauze
glauben dass so kann wissen du verpiss
dich ja jetzt alle drei auf einmal kommt
da genau genau wie ich habe ich gelesen
deswegen heißt auch exporte deswegen
gestellten einmal gewählt worden
ja sowieso alles was du machst du nimmst
mir meinen ganzen nürnberg auf einmal
knapp das war wichtig denn es wichtig
wichtig ein spammer games autofokus
alter ja nein
allgemein games autofokus alter alter
ich hab mich verguckt und das spiel
einfach komplett weg
die krankhafte krankhaft ist aber kein
fußball kräfte können es nicht
jaja dennis rasiere ich hab das gegen
laufe ich dann gemacht da nicht anders
so ja du hast dich so die abschluss
kills top können
ich meckere ich bin gerne in den
vollbildmodus weit am button macht kurze
pause alles klar
jungs entweder da alle warten ein
naja was ja nein junge der hund hat mich
gelockt könnte ich noch
junge alte werden damit bekommen dass
man uns holen
der kanzler nicht danken ungefähr jeder
folge bezogen
weißt du wer das nicht versteht der hat
nichts verstanden sein leben dennis du
schießt aufs tor hatten trotzdem du
läufst du ja genau
ja ja das machen jetzt hast du gesehen
hast du dem hof gesehen zwei aussteigen
lassen
genau jetzt schon wieder drei aussteigen
ja sowieso was die klappt immer ja durch
die schnauze einer gegen zwei
verteidigen
wir haben sowieso ein kuchen sowie
reiner calmund
ja denn es kommt der kann schon mal
reinmachen hier bist du bist ja sowie
verlängert denn es konnte ja dann ist
jetzt machen die macht zu blocken passt
ja was die billig okay das entscheidende
tor glaube ich nehme machen bis zehn
punkte entscheidend ja es ist egal jetzt
ja wenn es genau stelle ich vor dem wald
denn ist falsche richtung
ja und nein nein
immer auf tour immer kranich verletztes
tolles gameplay okay leute wenn euch das
gefallen hat hacks ball dann lasst ein
leica schreibt in die kommentare
mehr davon sehen wollt ich fand es
richtig gleich aus sagt auch gefallen
und dann sehen wir uns im nächsten video
wieder nach dem ja die ganzen kuren in
der beschreibung angeklickt haben
ok dann haut rein macht's gut